якби у Порошенка була можливість
зустрітися з орбаном і домовитися про те
щоби він не блокував зараз рішення
Європейської ради про відкриття
перемовин про членство з Україною то я
вважаю що Президент Зеленський мав би
просто просити Петра Порошенка Про те
щоби той зустрівся і спробував допомогти
йому розв'язати цю проблему яку сьогодні
У такий спосіб своїх політичних
внутрішніх завдань перетворює Орбан для
на нашої європейської інтеграції Мені
прикро що єдність вона залишається
декларованою єдність може забезпечити
виключно влада а ось такими своїми діями
знаєте можна скільки хочеш говорити про
єдність Скільки хочеш можна говорити про
демократію і таке інше але коли ти діями
показуєш що в країні ти будуєш
централізовану автократичну владу то це
насправді не сприяє нашому успішному
подальшому просуванн